so who is there I've been in San
Francisco for about two years and I
worked at two startups so far and so the
talk tonight I work at insightly now but
I'm actually going to talk about data
that I used in my last company which was
cause it's calm I don't know if you guys
have been causes it was a Shawn Parker
company that it was a social networking
platform for activism so and at the end
I'll talk about why why do you think
Austin is because that would be relevant
so first of all why would you do a
cluster analysis or user segmentation
analysis you do this because you want to
get to know your users and that's good
for a lot of reasons obviously marketing
building your product and optimizing for
them I've never worked in finance but
there's a gentleman in the room who has
if he you would say that they used to
cluster analysis at their hedge fund to
actually figure out price range for
different loans right yeah so if you're
doing that that's really good
information too
so yeah it causes we did this for all of
those reasons but then also merits are
what sensing the company that we were
building this product with a recent
blindfold on our engineers never
customers of course the marketing team
does in the customer service people do
but the engineer is the executive team
there a lot of people the company agent
didn't really understand we're building
this product for and so we thought it's
really important to like bring some
empathy into the company for our users
it's so we started this project
so first we'll give a data overview and
then the methods we used and our results
so first for a data overview we at
causes we had a lot of variation in our
data because we use Facebook Connect so
when people sign it that causes they did
a through Facebook and that gave us a
ton of information on gender location
their age and how many phrases they have
a bunch of stuff like that and I'm not
sure if Facebook Connect still works
that way this is a couple of years ago
but for a while we could just download
like tons of data from Facebook and so
we did that and and then we had our
behavioral data from our own website so
since it was an activist platform we
knew who the most active people were
what kinds of topics that are interested
in whether it's animal rights or human
rights or environmental justice and
things like that
so there's a wide variety of information
there and within platforms also social
networking site there too so you can see
how many connections person have with
other people on the platform so
influencers sort of proxy and then to
really round out the quantitative side
we did surveys and interviews and then
with our qualitative research team what
the UX people really helped with that
the market research people and then we
used um third-party sources to round out
some of our information that we had on
our users and please wrap believe yeah I
meant to look it up today because I
haven't looked at it for a couple of
years so maybe you guys will know but
you can you used to only give them email
addresses okay there's a bunch of
information about those users which
seems like pretty shady I don't know so
we had just on one user we had a lot of
current data that we use for our
analysis which is super helpful for us
really nervous about us having so much
data about them but but I mean our house
is free so uh oh yeah so anyway rapidly
does still exist and Risa okay yeah I
wasn't meant to look it up today I
forgot okay so first we started with um
the quantitative side so we we subset
our news you dip a random sample of two
hundred thousand users and our entire
years of main user baseless around a
hundred thousand or something I mean so
he took two hundred thousand users who
have been active in the last six months
to grant example that we just dumped all
of that data that we got from rapidly
for Facebook and that are on the website
and we put it through McKee means
clustering analysis and that was because
we needed to figure out how many
clusters that were and just like kind of
generally figure out how what who went
in and what cluster and one thing about
k-means clustering analysis is a lot of
people do it a low test what's called an
elbow test to figure out how many
clusters there should be and so I'm just
mentioned that quickly is one
it's Altima over look up an elbow test
because it basically tells you for how
many cluster for each additional cluster
review have how much more information is
gained in that cluster and so the line
will actually at the elbow of the line
is where you say okay like for cluster
this is kind of where we hit our maximum
yet each initial cluster it's not to
give us that much more information so
you want to stop in that elbow so so
first we ran it through we figured out
that about six clusters was our our
optimize cluster analysis and what does
he have everybody split into a cluster
you assign then that cluster main and
then run it through a decision tree
he's a random forest it's what we used
there are a couple of funny things about
random forests I mean the pros of using
random forests since they're really easy
and you can look them up online and it's
quick and it can do their job very
quickly but but the they have a thing
called importance that I haven't really
they don't find a good definition of so
if anybody here has one reason you know
but essentially the k-means clustering
their fear and how many clusters you
have and then your decision trees you
want to know which variables are the
most important for predicting those
- which cluster so so you look at the
importance of this random forest so it
in ours like Asia was the strongest
predictor of who ended up in the cluster
and then there are ten or fifteen
variables that were like the most
predictive each person ending up in
which cluster and we turn that with the
importance though it's just the bigger
the number the more important it is but
there's no real definition of importance
as far as I know so I guess that's still
the case
okay so then once we had everybody in
their clusters that we knew which
variables were most predictive that was
huge because then new people coming into
the system we've never seen before we
can kind of guess which cluster they
would end up in just based on their
characteristics and how similar they
were to other people so from that we
built recommendation engines for what
they actually saw on our website and
then we also and then
things like that but really we felt like
doing the quantitative side wasn't
enough and so to figure out deeply who
our users are and why they do the things
they do we sent out a lot of surveys we
had 1,500 responses and then from those
we picked 10 people from each cluster
and interviewed them so well it's
roughly I guess was roughly 11 and so we
did 65 interviews really quick this is
just the visualisation there were
cluster analysis so another kind of
another thing about doing a Keynes
cluster analysis is it it finds the mean
of each cluster let's call this centroid
and then find the distance of each user
or natively and and then starts to
cluster them together but you don't
really you can't really interpret what
it needs to be far apart so these
clusters are clustered together and so
you just kind of magnitude or like
generally note that these are you know
more similar clusters than these two at
the bottom but there's no there's no
real definitive way to say if these are
like X distance apart and this is how
different they are that's just kind of
but it gives you a good general idea of
what's going on so this was five of out
of our six more clusters we had a sixth
cluster that was that was kind of an
undifferentiated category so they're not
pictured in this visual
oh you know actually I'm not sure it's
been a while since I've done this
yeah I'm sorry for that yeah I know this
is visualization we did it in our and I
can't remember which package P is which
is such a bummer because I had one of
these I'd like to use it again but I
can't so um yeah so when you do
something like a means it's highly
sensitive to the distance metric areas
and essentially given that yeah
variables are separate returns like
kinds of oh he's off top of my head
let's see somebody throw out to me and
I'll tell your children ones I mean
there might have been in Euclidean gamma
baggage things gosh I have a white paper
about it and I was looking for it today
and I couldn't find it so yeah sorry but
but there is a ton of information on
Google when you are
figure this out you can compare all the
different distances and why
so yeah but so yeah just shut up and
track that ok so here's an example of a
decision tree just the the data getting
funneled down and then ending up in one
of the clusters at the bottom so then
for the surveys and interviews we had
our market research team in the UX team
go out and they really hustled I mean I
thought the quantitative side took
forever but they really put in a lot of
work so you know understanding why
people use your product and what you
know we really want to know what do you
do beyond like our product like what's
your day-to-day life length or how do we
really fit into your life and and then
we ended up with these personas that uh
you know internally the we call them I
mean externally we call them ambitious
activists practical activists and we
have all these these characteristics on
the side over here but internally we
actually drew pictures like we have an
artist who worked with us and he
actually drew faces and we gave them
names like I think the truth millennial
because they they're mostly male and
they're young we call them Zach like
this tenacious activist this is actually
its
we have like faces drawn and the names
given I mean the engineers and exact
even every of the company's like okay
like these are our people
this is humor abilities product for so
it's really helpful to be able to talk
about our users and their needs and have
everybody really understand so and oh
and then so I have to leave early
tonight because these early flight
tomorrow so to go pack but anyway just
write down my email address if you guys
have any questions but really quickly
why I wasn't sure it's slightly data
today is is because we I did this
evidence and when I first stop there I
was like oh let's do this cluster
analysis it's cool causes but one thing
is you can do the cluster analysis if
your product doesn't have a lot of
variation it is in like what your needs
are changing so insightly as a customer
relations
management tool and there just are it at
the time when I started it was still
very new and so we didn't have that much
stuff that people could do so everybody
kind of fell into one cluster why did
this keep happening it was just kind of
like there's not a variation in the data
and I know a lot of a lot of friends who
I talk to about its problem to
interrelate matter so if you tried to do
this in your company you keep ending up
like one cluster or a bunch of
overlapping clusters that's why it
should they're just not enough variation
in the data and so you know you can
always get more variation by outside
data but